if you want to know about the big secret
that Eddie kept from his friends then
stick around to the end of this video
I'm pretty sure only one member of the
losers Club the seven kids that battle
it's in the sewers of Derry Maine can
say that he's single-handedly saved all
of his friends from certain death and
that honor belongs to Eddie spaghetti
kasparek but despite his heroics Eddie
is subject to a lot of psychological
damage brought on by his past only some
of which is explored in the movie
adaptations my name is Professor Z's
world and today on Horn history you
wanted to see it to brings you one of
the most exciting episodes it's ever
been you're privileged to click on okay
kids see see the world is proud to
present dairy mains very own Luisi
[Applause]
[Music]
edward cass Brock was born in 1946 the
son of Frank Cass Bragg and his wife
Sonya in 1951 when Eddie was five years
old the two events would take place that
would change the course of entire life
first his father died of cancer then
Eddie himself nearly died when he got a
particularly bad fever his mother Sonia
was likely grief-stricken at the
prospect of nearly being left alone she
had lost one of her boys and was not
going to lose the other so she became
obsessed with protecting Eddie's health
to the point where she develops a
disorder known as factitious disorder or
when someone falsely claims that another
person has symptoms of illness injury or
disease with the intention of deceiving
others in other words Sonia would invent
medical conditions for Eddie in order to
keep him out of anything that she
perceived to be possibly dangerous like
gym class or pretty much going outside I
want to be a train conductor and see the
world
your mama religion across the street
Eddie seasoned the first effects of the
factitious disorder when his mother
takes him to get new shoes for an
upcoming wedding after mrs. Kaye
rejected many shoes for her son he
wandered off and discovered a machine he
didn't know what it was but in reality
it was a shoe fitting fluoroscope an
x-ray machine that they used to have in
shoe stores instead of just using all
these things for some reason when his
mom noticed him using this machine she
flipped out and dashed towards him
making a scene in the store while
screaming
and he get off of that she screamed get
off of there
those machines can give you a cancer get
off of that ready Eddie the whole scene
startled Eddie so much that he nearly
fell off the fluoroscope
but his mom got there just in time to
catch on and from this point forward she
was so overprotective of him that he
would never even get a minor injury for
the next seven years but she would not
stop there in 1954 when Eddie was 8
Sonia took him to the doctor
and despite Eddie saying he was fine she
pressured his physician dr. handler to
prescribing him asthma medication the
aspirator that he got really just
contained water vapor with a slight
medicinal taste but Eddie came to
believe that he couldn't survive without
it
and became very reliant on it whenever
he felt slightly uncomfortable his
mother got him on other medications as
well but the aspirator is something that
Eddie would always have with him because
of the way he was raised and he becomes
a hypochondriac someone with an intense
obsession about their health it even
gets to the point that Sonia starts to
isolate her son from other children in
Eddie's fifth grade year his mom screams
at the PE teacher for letting him
participate
it's claiming him that he's too fragile
to take part in and no showers with the
other boys this week
despite all of this Eddie had an
uncharacteristic fascination with
building a soapbox racer his dream was
to build the fastest racer and take it
to a competition in Ohio to win the
grand prize his mother actually allowed
him to work on this project in the
garage with no intention of ever letting
him take the vehicle out thinking that
he's never actually gonna get that far
his interest in taking the wheel of a
soapbox racer may have led to his
eventual career as a limousine driver
and the eventual owner of his own limo
company but I think the biggest
contributing factor was his impeccable
sense of direction when he and Bill
dendro first started playing in the
Barrens Eddy was always the one who
helped him navigate back out on their
own
in 1957 Eddy helped Bill tune up his
bike silver but after the death of
Bill's brother later that year Eddy
would also sometimes play alone near the
little travel to niebolt Straits near
the train yard one day in 1958 a drunken
train man threw out a crate from the
train and told Eddy to take it home to
his mother he did not open it but he
could tell it was filled with slippery
crawly things he might have just left
the box there if the Train man hadn't
mentioned his mother but Eddy has the
psychological weakness when it comes to
his mom so he obeys after dragging the
create home mrs. Kay is delighted to
find that the crate is filled with
lobster but Eddy refused to eat them
because he was constantly reminded of
the clicking sound that they made he
probably would have strongly disliked
hereditary his fear of the lobsters may
be related to his eventual demise
lobsters are eaten by pulling off each
of the parts such as the claws and legs
and removing the meat from inside when
Eddie dies in 1985 the creature in the
form of a giant spider pulls off his arm
that was also the last southern seacoast
train that Eddy ever saw come through
Derry and it represents how he can never
leave his mother how he's trapped in her
vise grip you might even call it lobster
lighting one day at he was playing near
the train yard again when a hobo crawled
out from under the porch of an abandoned
house at 29 niebolt streets the hobo
offered to do Eddie a favor for a
quarter and Eddie realizes the man has
leprosy which scares him and sends him
running for his bike although Eddie was
scared by the incident he acquired a
strange fascination with twenty-nine
kneeble Street and comes back to
investigate it he crawls under the porch
and discovers a face staring back at him
from the basement window this thing
resembled the hobo but it was something
else the forehead was split open and
covered in yellow mucus the thing breaks
open the window and comes after Eddy
wearing a silvery clown suit with a big
orange buttons it introduces itself as
Bob gray and as Eddie runs it gained
ground on him and it told him to come
back anytime and bring his friends to he
didn't look back until he was nearly
home one night while Eddie was laying in
bed he heard the voice of the leper
whisper in his ear telling him it won't
do any good to Ron
stay tuned for more horror history
[Music]
it was June of 1958 when the town's
biggest bully Henry Bowers destroyed
Bill and Eddie's Dam in the Barrens
while looking for Ben Hanscom giving him
a bloody nose and an asthma attack then
comes out of hiding to stay with Eddie
while bill runs to the drugstore to
refill at his aspirator while he's gone
they discussed their own theories about
the killer that's been taking kids in
Derry and Eddie tells Ben not to mention
Bill's brother George who was one of the
victims Ben is also covered in blood and
Eddie gives him the idea to buy a
milkshake and spill half of it on
himself so that his mother won't find
out about the blood the next time they
meet up to build the dam Eddie worries
about his mother yelling at him for
taking off his shoes in the stream and
putting him at risk of getting a cold
Eddie's annoyed with his pal Richie
Tozier because he doesn't like how rich
she calls him ads in the miniseries the
unwanted nickname is Eddie spaghetti
don't call me Eddie spaghetti later that
day the spaghetti man shares a story
about the leper encounter with a group
and they conclude that what each of them
saw was connected that afternoon he
helps the other boys clear up the dam
after getting in trouble with the police
officer mr. Nell Eddie is not present
when Richie Tozier organises the outing
to the Aladin theatre because his mom
was making him visit his fat single
aunts who lived in Haven Bangor and
Hampton but he was present today that
Beverly told him Ben and Bradley Donovan
about the blood that she saw in her
bathroom saying they sneak in the back
door so that Beverly's neighbor doesn't
tell her father that she had boys over
and like Beverly they're all able to see
the blood that her parents could not and
offer to help her clean it up the
calendar rolls over to July and Eddie
and his friends are playing Safari in
the Barrens as they crossed the stream
they pretended that it was full of
piranhas
he looked into the bright water and for
one moments between the Sun flashes that
darted arrows of light into his eyes he
actually saw the cruising piranhas they
were not part of the make-believe that
went with Bill's jungle safari fantasy
he was quite sure of that the fish she
saw looked like oversized goldfish with
great ugly jaws of catfish or groupers
saw teeth protruded between their thick
lips and like goldfish they were orange
as orange as the fluffy pom-poms you
sometimes saw on the suits the clown's
wore the circus
this incident highlights the connection
between the kids imaginations and it's
their creativity is what makes them more
delicious targets which is why most of
its victims are human children but their
imaginations are also their greatest
weapon against ads and we see more of
that later
in the summer the kids tried to go to
the dump but were chased off by mr.
Fosse oh and they ended up going to the
gravel pits where they meet up with Mike
Hanlon and help him fend off the Bowers
gang in a brutal Rock fights at the end
of the battle Eddy has an asthma attack
and has to relieve himself using his
aspirator a few days later on July 6th
the rain pushes one of penny wisest
victims Jimmy Coulomb out into the Sun
we're bill and Eddie passed within 40
yards of it while bringing in boards for
their Clubhouse in the Barrens
later that day Mike shows the others his
father's dairy photo album and one of
the pages comes to life because of its
and takes many forms to try to scare
them one of which is the leper that Eddy
had seen at 29 needles
later that month after the group had
attempted to perform the smoke hole
ritual Eddie went to the pharmacy to
pick up medication for his mother and
himself was July 20th and on this
occasion and the pharmacist mr. keen
called Eddie into his office do you know
what a placebo is Eddie I gotta go it's
water
Eddie water with a squirt of camphor to
make it taste like medicine the doctor
is weak and your mother's determined
that you're ill and you my friend are
caught in the middle mr. Keane uses a
balloon to demonstrate how Eddie's lungs
are condensed by his uptight posture and
that may actually have been the cause of
his breathing problems he explains how a
placebo works and Eddie panics upon
hearing this information and breaks an
ice-cream glass mr. Keane promises not
to tell his mother that he broke the
glass in exchange for keeping their
conversation a secret it's quite the
opposite of how it played out in the
2017 movie see what means Bush after
leaving centre street drug Eddie runs
into Costello markets and when he comes
back out on the street he encounters the
bullies and they are looking for revenge
for what happened during the rock fights
two weeks ago
Eddi spots the bullies shortly after
coming out of Costello's tree market he
tries to go back inside the store but
Henry grabs hold of him before he gets
the chance Patrick and Vic can beat up
on him and Henry pins him to the ground
and fills his mouth up with gravel
before it can escalate any further an
adult who works at the market grabbed
Henry but instead of ending it then and
there Henry fights back and pushes him
down before telling him to go back
inside a command that mr. goudreau
actually obeys and goes back to call the
cops
although he was unable to save Eddie it
did allow enough time for Eddie to run
for it and he's almost able to escape
until he gets to the corner and collides
with a little kid on a tricycle Richard
Cowen he goes down and Henry comes down
hard on him and breaks his arm when this
happens
Eddie's surprises Henry when he starts
laughing the reason for this once again
goes back to Eddie's mother she
sheltered him all these years been so
overprotective of him that he's never
broken anything before thinking back to
that moment at the shoe store he's never
even felt real pain and because of this
he's lived in fear of getting injured
and Bilt's the idea of it up in his mind
is the worst thing ever
so when he actually feels one of the
most painful things happen it's not as
bad as he imagined it to be and he
starts laughing the police officer mr.
nel eventually found him but not before
Patrick spit in his face which I imagine
it was the most traumatic parts giving
Eddie's hypochondriasis in the ambulance
Eddie briefly sees Pennywise the clown
as the driver but on second inspection
realizes it's just some guy with a crew
cuts as expected Eddie's mom makes a
huge scene at the hospital acting like
she knows better than all the doctors
and I think it's important to note how
his broken arm was a blessing in
disguise for him he finally has the
awakening about his mother that mr. Kean
had tried to give him earlier in the day
and suggest that she leave him alone
while the doctors treat him Sonya is
shocked and sees this as an act of
defiance after visiting hours end Eddie
sees the sunset out his window only it's
a huge orange clown pom-pom button just
like the piranhas he had seen in the
Barrens he falls asleep in dreams that
his friends came to visit him in the
hospital but his mom's hold them off in
the waiting room telling them that Eddie
doesn't want to be friends with them
anymore
Pennywise is also sitting in the waiting
room but Eddie's the only one to know
it then displays several other forms the
last of which has mrs. Kasper acts phase
suggesting that she too may be a part of
its influence at the end of the dream
Eddie realizes he was unable to
intervene because he was dead he was a
ghost and that is a trick we call
foreshadowing because Eddie dies not
right now but later the dream sequence
may have been an instance of shining for
Eddie because he was seeing a slightly
different version of the real fight
between his mom and his friends that
occurred outside the hospital oh I've
heard of you miss Marsh and I don't want
a dirty girl like you touching my son
Eddie is upset with his mother for
sending his friends away so she changes
tactics to get control back over herself
a study from the University College
London which sounds like a made-up
University name that a high school
dropout made to impress a girl at a
party but it's not found that there are
two ways that a parent tends to control
their child behavioural control and
psychological control child psychologist
Nancy darling describes a method of the
latter that the parent may use guilt
induction or make the child's feel that
they won't be loved if they don't do
what the parents wants the core of
psychological control is that it
assaults the child self so Sonia starts
crying to make Eddie feel bad but he's
able to see through her act he calls her
out on giving him the placebo asthma
medication and although he's not putting
up with his mother's behavior anymore
his hypochondriasis is rooted to deep
inside of him and he uses the aspirator
as soon as she leaves he would go back
to sleep this time dreaming of a dark
place were pumping machinery ran on and
on and he would soon discover its source
eventually the rest of the losers Club
returns to the hospital while mrs. Kaye
isn't there and they're able to see
Eddie and sign is cast and they describe
the plan that they have to attack is
Eddie sees this event as something like
a contract that they sign and they would
make good on that contract a couple of
days after Eddie was released from the
hospital by showing up at the house
where Eddie had his first encounter with
its 29 kneeble streets
Eddie's aspirator goes around and each
member of the losers Club takes one puff
before going in and fighting Pennywise
before going in Eddie notices that the
Roses that the leper had touched during
his first encounter had died with all
seven of them united they're able to
drive the monster down into the sewers
the last real day of Eddie's childhood
came on August 10th when
in town with Richie and Stan on a
strangely silent afternoon they end up
meeting up with everyone else and
Beverly warns them about her recent
encounter with Henry Bowers who had
snapped and tried to kill her
bill realizes that it is starting to
control Henry and the seven of them
decide that now is the time to put an
end to it they drop Edie's Parcheesi
board in the clubhouse and head to the
sewers but Eddy has the feeling that's
they're being watched as the seven of
them headed to the pumping station where
they could enter the sewers a rock came
out of the bushes and hit mice it was
Henry belch and Victor a storm brews
above them as they flee to the pumping
station Eddy is unable to climb the
ladder on his own with his cast and
rides unbuild back Eddy's bravery shines
through here perhaps more than any other
time the boy who earlier that summer had
reservations about waiting in the stream
and the Barons because of bacteria who's
now trudging through the pipes flowing
with literal water but his most heroic
moment was yet to come
he was asked to lead the way because of
his impeccable sense of direction and as
he did so he sense that it had been
there after traveling for a while Eddy
has the realization that they're now
deeper than the sewer pipes should
normally go and we're now at the level
of mine shafts or something just then
the group is attacked by it's in the
form of a giant eye with six tentacles
that grabs bill then Beverly Ritchie
Stan and my Eddy may have been the one
left unrestrained because it believed
that he'd be the weakest with his broken
arm but the monster underestimates
Eddy's strong imagination Eddy believes
that his aspirator contains battery acid
and sprays it into the eye causing
immense pain to it and fouls that up
with a little combo action by delivering
a series of kicks to the eye as if this
were some kind of Legend of Zelda boss
he actually lost his shoe when it got
stuck in the jelly of the eye and
hearing Eddy's aggressive screams as he
saved his friends gave them the strength
to get free the eye disappeared the next
attack came from the giant bird which
swoops in and caused Eddy
this time stan is the one to save them
and they follow a pile of children's
bones to make it to the lair of it it is
here that Bill has his interdimensional
battle with it and upon coming out Eddy
claims that he heard the monster dying
as it retreated deeper into the sewers
they couldn't stick around to find out
for sure the chamber was flooding
because of the storm
and the group counted on Eddie to get
them out but it was at this point that
Eddie went from being like Google Maps
to being like Apple Maps and started to
get lost the group felt that they were
drifting apart an early symptom of the
memory loss that would occur when they
all left Derry it was only Bev's love
that could reunite them and make Eddie
realise where he had turned wrong good
word choice out of everyone it was the
easiest for Eddie to make the promise
that they'd come back if it wasn't dead
because he believed the most that they
had killed it unfortunately for Eddie he
was wrong he stayed in Derry for at
least a couple years until he and his
mother relocated to Queens New York when
Eddie became a young man he tried to
escape his mother on three separate
occasions but I think it was because he
didn't have the shared power of his
friends in the losers Club and he was
unable to fight Sonja's psychological
control like he did that day in the
hospital and he ended up returning home
all three times mrs. Cass bragging never
wanted her son to go away to college or
get married luckily for him he had a
natural talent for navigation and
driving leading him to eventually start
his own limousine company royal crest
limousine despite becoming successful he
continued to live with his mother she
continued to obsess over his health into
his adulthood and continued to neglect
her own and by the age of 64 her weight
exceeded 400 pounds besides that even
Ben Hanscom couldn't have dreamed of
reaching in the year 1980 Sonia Castro
died of congestive heart failure when
Eddie goes in for his own checkup later
that year his doctor notices the
greenstick fracture and asked if he fell
out of a tree as a kid Eddie can't even
remember how he had broken his arm back
in the summer of 58 in 1981 he leaves
home one more time but ends up coming
back with Myra a fellow limo driver who
he decided to make his wife just like
his mother she's a regular porker what a
horror and Eddie thinks he may have
married her because of her strong
resemblance to Sonja a resemblance so
strong that they just decided to toss
the wife character in the 1990
miniseries and have Eddie just still
living with his mother Eddie and his
wife relocates the Long Island New York
when Eddie gets the call from Mike
Hanlon about the return of its in 1985
his wife uses the same psychological
tactics that his mom would have used on
it making him feel guilty for leaving
her as the memories of his past trickle
back his asthma worsens as well and he
has a thought about coming back
Eddie has one of his drivers take him to
Penn Station where he's able to catch
train to Cape Cod or another limo
company that he has an affiliation with
lensing the car that he takes the rest
of the way back to Derry Maine for the
first time since his childhood Eddie
goes to a reunion lunch at the Chinese
restaurant where Mike catches them all
up on what has gone down in Derry when
they get their fortune cookies at the
end of the meal each cookie is
manipulated by EDS and the mutated
cricket that comes out of Eddie's cookie
reminds him of the crickets that he's
never been able to exterminate from his
basement it's a bit different in the
mini series that Eddie
so chuckle Isha's the losers plan to
meet up again at the library that night
and in the meantime Eddie gets off the
bus at a random cross street of Kansas
Street he comes up on tracker brush
truck Depot which was the prime spot for
playing baseball as a kid though Eddie
would only shag balls because his mom
believed he would get hurt if he played
while Eddie is alone here at the
now-defunct truck Depot he notices a
concrete cylinder with the label Derry
Public Works and remembers it as one of
the entrances to the sewers that's when
he hears a voice inviting him to come
play
[Music]
Eddie had only seen two balls hit over
the fence at tracker bros both came off
the bat of belt Huggins this was well
before the baseballs were juiced in 2019
and in one of the two home runs belch
actually knocked the cover off the ball
just then in 1985 a similar coverless
ball flies back onto the field of play
as if it were some kind of Paul
Goldschmidt home run at Wrigley Field
man I hate that guy strongly dislike I
mean strongly dislike him then Eddie
sees belch climb over the fence though
this was no ordinary belch he looked
like the leper from 29 needles the
canvas squares that the kids used as
bases rose from the ground and flew at
Eddie
Tony Tracker who would often watch the
kids play back in 58 came out of the
ground at home plate and what I can only
imagine look like a demented mega
evolution of diglettz then he sees a
zombified version of his childhood crush
greta bowie and she tells him that she
had died in a car accident when she was
18 which may be it's essentially telling
Eddie that he'll never be with the girl
he wants he'll be stuck with someone who
is the equivalent of his mom forever
Eddie also sees Patrick hochstätter
zombie as he ran for it eventually
collapsing and she was safe in McCarren
Park that nights they all made at the
library and everyone brings booze Eddie
brings a gin and prune juice because he
thinks it would be healthy if you don't
already know this if something has
alcohol it does not qualify as healthy
not even white claw and that stuff's
more watered-down than paramours last
two albums it uses its influence on the
town to chase them out of the library so
they go back to the hotel where Eddie
sees his aspirator roll across the table
by itself and notices balloons tied to
the podium at the front desk reading
asthma medication gives you cancer
a likely taunt from it's about the
absence of Eddie's father everyone goes
back to their rooms and after some time
Eddie hears a knock on his door and a
voice tells him that it's the bellboy
with a message from his wife as he's
opening the door he realizes that this
was no bellboy
it was Henry Bowers coming at him with a
knife Eddie closes the door on his arm
and the knife drops but Henry is able to
force his way in
Eddie smashes a bottle and stabs at
Henry's eyes they tussle and Henry
shoves him back into a table falling
down and impaling himself on the bottle
but Eddie's arm is once again broken in
the process
spill Beverly Richie and Ben reconvene
at Eddie's room
Henry's knife has somehow disappeared
and Henry was dead but after finding out
Mike was also attacked they wanted to
take no more chances they decided to go
to the Barrens and finish what they
started 27 years ago they piled into
Eddie's limo and when they arrived in
the Barrens the manhole cover was
already open waiting for them the
pumping machinery was off just as it was
that August day in 1958 and again Eddie
has to go down into the sewers on Bill's
back Eddie navigated them once more to
reach the lair of the spider or at least
what they perceived to be the spider
you'll see Bill engages in the
interdimensional mind battle with Ed's
and Ritchie joins him so Eddie Beverly
and Ben are the only ones conscious in
the real physical chamber but Eddie can
momentarily see the form of his mom's
head it takes shape on the spider he
senses his friends are in danger and
tries to help like he did in 1958 roll
it this is battery acid
now you disappear
[Applause]
in the novel eddie reaches into the
spider's jaws and sprays the aspirator
and it bites down and rips Eddie's arm
off with ease leaving him to bleed out
on the floor of the chamber last time
[Music]
those were the last words that came out
of Edie's mouth his vision about coming
back to New York and a hearse however
would not become a reality as his
friends were desperate to escape after
defeating it they were in bad condition
and had a carry Bill's catatonic wife
who they rescued their they left Eddie's
body behind as the chamber began to
flood once more and felt that it was
somehow fitting that this is where Eddie
was supposed to be
Eddie Cass Brack was never the most
physically gifted member of the losers
Club but it was his mental strength that
allowed him to save his friends lives as
kids but unfortunately for him without
the returned support for most of his
life he was unable to break away from
the psychosomatic stranglehold of his
mother even after her death and he was
unable to replicate his magic when he
went up against it as an adult to fully
understand the losers Club you'll need
to see these episodes of horror history
for my analysis but first make sure you
subscribe to see these worlds from new
horrors every week bring the death
battle for notifications and I'll see
you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]